good morning John while we were on tour
someone suggested that I redo an awful
lot of running with an awful lot of
driving and so I did that when I first
saw this two of us I was like what those
sweet leather seats
kredel a my but play an Xbox 360 and
kicking John's ass I only can hope steel
in will lad I was waiting stage left and
I'm cutting up hard on my tights I'm
prepping my tutu and hoping it'll all be
alright like I do every freaking night
I'm either so freakin bored or am on top
of the world a shirt on stage my chorus
of scream stop in 17 places and 21 days
with cookies in gas station food and an
awful lot of driving to do
[Music]
two notes first of all I am sick so
sorry if I'm not my usual boisterous
self second I finally got my glasses
that you voted for all those ages ago
they have anti-reflective coating on
them which is wonderful for a scishow if
you've seen it's quite bad there was
another note no I did both of them
nevermind
Jonathan and I kept saying we did it
after the last show after we got back to
the hotel after we got to the airport
the next morning after we landed in
Missoula after we slid our gold sad
pathetic bodies into our old wonderful
familiar bed we just kept saying did it
and I really want to look back on the
last three weeks and think about the
thing that we did but I'm having a
really hard time doing that probably
partially because of all nyquil also the
disputes be something very strange going
on my brain right now might be blank
tell me something fun that happened
while you're on tour I can't think of
any three things like three weeks of my
life are gone it both lasted forever and
amounted to no time at all it's like the
two pieces of my life that existed
before and after tour have just sucked
together and tour was like it's like a
directory structure in a computer it's
like one little file contains all of
that information and in order to get any
of the information I have to like dive
down through it and none of it relates
in any way to the normal way that I
lived my life and so I can't
contextualize it to the normal Hank life
it's making me seriously bonded the
limitations my brain which is not
something that I particularly want to be
doing while I have this headache I think
it's really vital to do things like this
to do things that are outside of your
comfort zone I've got a big core son of
the most people don't have the
opportunity to view the thing that we
just did the three week long tour with
people all like like screaming and
knowing the words to the songs that I
wrote which is we all have opportunities
to do things that are outside of our
comfort zone and I think that we should
whether that's volunteering at a
homeless shelter or just going to some
place you wouldn't normally go like like
somewhere where they line dance go to a
place where they line dance and see how
that world works is that is the only way
to really understand all the different
perspectives in the world and if we
don't understand the various
perspectives we just start to hate each
other and be like why are you trying to
ruin our Gondry's now
apparently about politics anyway we did
it we definitely did it there are a lot
of people who made this possible not
least the people who came out to enjoy
it and we're so enthusiastic and excited
and just really cool thank you so much
to all of you and I don't know how I got
to be this lucky person but now I'm
gonna go to bed is that cool John I'll
see you on Tuesday
[Music]